Welcome students to
the Pharmacology of the
Ganglionic and
Neuromuscular Nicotinic
Receptor Antagonists.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
We've been talking
in previous lectures
about drugs active
at the muscarinic
receptors, whether
activators or blockers,
and now we will
switch over to
blockers of the
nicotinic receptors.
Please do contact
me if you'd like
to have a chat
about pharmacology.
These are the
learning objectives.
They are titles
as you can see
with the learning
objectives indicated
in the following
sentences.
I provide you with a lot
of learning resources.
you simply do not
need to use them all.
I'm sure by now you're
finding out what types
of resources you do
like to use in order
for that new learning
to go into your brain.
You may use the videos
if you wish. You may
use the PowerPoints.
You may use textbooks.
I highly recommend
practice questions.
and I certainly
have my own practice
questions required
because they will help you
to see how I write
questions for the exams
and they give you a
board-style question
and in the answers I
explain the reasoning.
This whole thing is
to help you apply
pharmacologic concepts
to integrate them.
Here are the list of
learning resources
that I have
recommended. There are
certainly more. If
you use books that you
like better than
these, by all means do.
The review books all
contain practice
questions.
And of course,
ScholarRx bricks
also contain
practice questions.
The key points that
are following are
intended to help you to
grasp the main ideas,
the answer to what
is it I need to know.
I have organized
them according to
the learning objectives,
so each slide
is one of the
learning objectives.
We'll not go through
them, you're perfectly
capable of doing
that if you wish to.
And that brings us to the
beginning of the lecture.
As a brief review and
focusing now on the
nicotinic receptors
and with this extremely
simplified figure
here on the left
side the spinal column
here the neurons
autonomic nervous system
neurons coming out
neuromuscular neurons
coming out the
nicotinic receptors
I am circling now.
And these are
the receptors
that we will be
talking about.
Ganglionic receptors,
of course we
have a nicotinic
receptor at the
adrenal medulla
and neuromuscular
junction.
Parasympathetic,
sympathetic.
The drug that we will
be talking about is
mechamilamine. There
are a couple of others
that this one's no
longer in use. This
one is experimental
only. This one is still
manufactured and
marketed, but it's really
rarely used. So you
may ask yourself
the question, well,
if they're not used,
why do I need to
learn them? Why are
they included in a
pharmacology lecture?
Because if you can
understand all the
mechanisms and side
effects, the mechanism and
all of the side
effects that occur with
mechamilamine, then
you will have a strong
understanding of the
autonomic nervous system.
Here are the circles.
And this, we'll begin
with the ganglion,
the ganglionic blockers.
So ganglion, ganglion,
this is actually not
ganglion, this is
adrenal medulla, but
it will be affected.
Ganglion and ganglion.
We'll talk about
the pharmacology of
the ganglionic
blocking drugs now.
They are non-depolarizing
neuronal blockers
of these neuronal
nicotinic receptors.
So they block the
ganglionic transmission
of parasympathetic
and sympathetic
autonomic ganglia. as
well as the adrenal
medulla. Compare this
to nicotine, which
causes dose-dependent
depolarizing block.
Nicotine, of course,
is an agonist.
And persistent presence
of nicotine at the
junction will cause
the depolarizing block.
Mechamelamine is the
example we'll use.
It has a really
kind of interesting
mechanism of action,
which is why I'm starting
with it. It's called
a channel plug.
When the agonist,
and we'll
think about
acetylcholine here,
blocks the open
channel pore,
sorry,
when acetylcholine
opens the channel,
the drug will get
inside and block the
channel pore When
the agonist unbinds,
the channel closes
around the drug, and
that traps the drug
molecule inside.
Persistent
block cannot be
overcome by adding
more agonist.
Looking at the
structure activity
relationship now,
the figure of
mechamelamine structure
is at the bottom.
the arrow is
pointing to the amino
group there and we
see that it has two
bonds so it has a
bicyclic oops hold
on a second has a
bicyclic structure
and that fits into
the channel pore
and it has lower
affinity for the
neuromuscular
nicotinic acetylcholine
receptors. So we're
thinking about
ganglia, not
neuromuscular block.
In terms of
pharmacokinetics, it is
available ******.
It's greeted unchanged
in the urine and has
the duration anywhere
between six and
more than 12 hours.
It does cross the
blood-brain barrier,
uncharged and lipophilic,
and it will inhibit the
central nicotinic
acetylcholine receptors.
And just
incidentally, it is a
weak base, so acidic
urine increases
the rate of of
excretion and may
decrease the
therapeutic effect.
The other two
are trimethophan,
competitive
antagonist that does
not cross the blood
-brain barrier.
It is not widely
available,
if available at all.
Hexamethonium is this
six carbon structure
and it's only used
experimentally.
it's never been used as a
therapeutic for
humans or animals.
Now you may be
thinking oh my
goodness with all
of these with all
of with inhibition
of both the
parasympathetic
and the sympathetic
and the adrenal
medulla there
must be a lot
of responses
that can occur
and that's true.
Responses to treatment
with ganglionic
blockers are complex and
largely unpredictable,
which I'll go into
on the next slide.
The big points are that
ganglionic blockers
suppress the outflow,
because they're
inhibitors, from the
nicotinic receptors
in both the
parasympathetic, sympathetic
ganglia, and at the
adrenal medulla.
And as a result, that's
going to suppress
all autonomic flow
out of that area.
Also, they suppress the
homeostatic reflexes.
So I'll give
you an example
of that in a moment.
Homeostatic reflexes
are important
for keeping us in
homeostasis. They
moderate, in this
case, the autonomic
responses. So this
is suppressed.
The homeostatic reflexes
that will adjust
the heart rate
is suppressed.
The vasculature
Neurologic, muscle,
neurohumeral
reflexes, all suppressed.
So I want to mention
the mechanism of
baroreceptor signaling.
this will keep coming up.
I know you haven't
had the cardiovascular
system yet, but this
is easy to understand.
It's quite logical. I
put a picture here on
the right-hand side of
the carotid sinuses,
baroreceptors, and
the baroreceptors in
the aortic arch. So
that's what we're going
to be referring to
when we talk about
baroreceptors. Their
normal function is
to moderate responses
in blood pressure.
They transmit
signals from the
baroreceptors
to the brain and
back to the
effector organs.
So an example is,
two examples, are if
there is a rapid fall
in blood pressure,
this is sensed by
the baroreceptors.
A fall in blood
pressure, what
does the body need
to do? It needs
to bring the
pressure back up.
So, the baroreceptor
sends signal to the
medulla oblongata,
and that will
disinhibit the sympathetic
nervous system,
which will cause
increased tone coming
out of the ganglia,
out of the medulla,
through the ganglia, to
cause vasoconstriction,
increased heart
rate. and that
will help bring up
the blood pressure.
Now on the other
hand, a rapid rise
in blood pressure
also sensed by the
baroreceptors. So
what does the body
need to do? It
needs to moderate
by bringing down
the blood pressure.
Again, signals are sent
to the medulla oblongata
and back to the
parasympathetic nervous
system which has
increased tone, increased
activity, And that will
slow the heart rate
and will cause some
vasodilation as well and
lower the blood
pressure. So that's what
we're talking about
with autonomic reflexes.
In this case, the
blood pressure
reflexes. So the
suppression of blood
pressure reflexes,
this baroreceptors,
which the activity
through the ganglia
is needed, but now
it's suppressed,
so we don't get
those autonomic
reflexes to changes
in blood pressure.
Here we have the
chart of the various
effects that the ganglion
blockers can cause.
It's easiest to
think about this in
terms of dominant
tone. So what is the
dominant tone coming
out of the sympathetic
nervous system,
out of the
parasympathetic nervous
system? So let's think
about it in the
resting individual.
the dominant tone for
the arterioles and
veins is sympathetic
because there's
always a basal amount
of sympathetic activity
to keep our blood
pressure at a
homeostatic level so
arterioles and veins
the dominant tone is
sympathetic and that's
going to cause some
vasoconstriction
What is the
opposite effect that
occurs because the
ganglionic nicotinic
receptors are
blocked? Well, it's
going to be
opposite, dilation,
instead of
vasoconstriction, dilation.
So mechamelamine
causes dilation of the
veins and arterioles.
I have put in bold
here, severe orthostatic
hypotension is
a side effect of
mechamelamine because,
remember,
the reflexes are
also blunted.
Normally, when we
go from a lying down
position to a
standing up position,
the baroreceptors sense
the lowering of blood
pressure, particularly
in the lower
extremities, and send a
message to constrict and
push the blood right
back up to the heart.
Since these reflexes
are blunted,
the veins don't
constrict and therefore
syncope, fainting,
can happen.
Patients will
feel kind of
dizzy, a sort
of dizziness,
a lightheadedness, a
sort of a veil falling
over their eyes and
could lead to fainting.
the parasympathetic
is the dominant tone
at rest think rest and
digest so what's the
dominant tone the
parasympathetic tone in
the heart that would
be a slowed heart
rate blocking the
ganglia a fast heart rate
in the eye the iris So
we get some meiosis,
block that, we get
a little medriasis.
The ciliary muscle
is important
for contraction
of the lens so
that we can see
at near vision.
This gets blocked.
So the cycloplegia,
this effect of
the ciliary muscle
is paralyzed.
loss of accommodation.
These two together,
blurred vision.
It's hard to write
on the screen
so it's a little
bit messy.
GI tract, the
parasympathetic
rest and digest.
digest. So
there would be
increased tone,
increased
motility, increased
secretions, and
this gets blocked.
And motility can
be profoundly
affected. That can cause
marked constipation.
The secretion of
gastric acid is reduced.
The drugs, however,
are not effect really
effective at reducing
acid enough to
treat peptic ulcer
this is because acid
secretion is related to
a number of different
systems not just
the parasympathetic
system urinary
bladder well promotes
micturition what can
happen if it's blocked
urinary retention
and we see this
particularly in males
with prostatic hyperplasia
because that prostate
is enlarged and
it's pushing on the
urinary equipment.
The ******* tract,
well, both of these get
blocked, so
****** impairment.
Salivary glands,
salivary glands
are really sensitive to
stimulation by the
parasympathetics.
So what do we get?
Dry mouth, xerostomia
is another word
for dry mouth.
Sweat glands, yes
these are sympathetic.
There is as I said
a low level of
sympathetic activity,
a basal level
it's called. at
all times and sweat
glands are important
for sweating,
obviously.
This is especially
important for
when the
temperature is high,
ambient, oops, when
ambient temperature
is high. Oh, look at
this, a new thing.
So I won't write. So
ambient temperature is
high or we're exercising.
We need to sweat.
And the ganglion
blockers prevent that
sweating. And that's
called anhydrosis.
So please be familiar
with sites of action,
dominant tone in
these various sites,
parasympathetic
really being the major
tone except for the
vasculature, and of
course sweat glands
because the sweat glands
are not innovated by
the parasympathetic
system even though
they are cholinergic.
And the effects
of blocking.
Now, we talked
about the effects
in terms of resting tone.
What if the person is
under stress and the
dominant tone is
sympathetic? So you know
what happens when
the dominant tone is
sympathetic. We get
all of these different
things happening,
vasoconstriction, increased
increased heart rate,
increased sweating,
and all these various
functions. So that
would all be reversed
in the individual
with an up-regulated
sympathetic tone.
Well, what would we
use mechamelamine
for? Traditionally,
it's been
used for hypertension
treatment.
It was developed
long before,
well I don't know about
how long, but it was
developed before the
drugs that are currently
used for the management
of hypertension.
The current drugs are
much more selective,
much better tolerated
than mechamelamine.
I want to emphasize
again the orthostatic
hypotension that
can be severe
because of these
absent baroreceptor
reflexes. Drug
interactions,
high, and this is
related to drugs
that have the
same effects, it's
related to drugs
that actually
act at the
effector organs.
They will still
be, they will still
have an effect
because they're acting
directly on the
effector organs whereas
the mechamelamine
is acting upstream.
Contraindications,
these really are
important, but you can
really predict them.
So a patient with
coronary insufficiency
or recent myocardial
infarction,
well, we're reducing
the sympathetic output
by blocking the
sympathetic ganglia.
Pyloric stenosis,
that's going to cause
gastric stasis, and
we know these drugs
are already, they
already reduce motility.
Glaucoma. By causing
cycloplegia and
medriasis, that is
going to reduce the
outflow of the aqueous
humor at the canal
of Schlem. That can
cause an increase in
intraocular pressure,
which can exacerbate
glaucoma. With uremia,
reduced blood flow to
the kidney. So reduced
blood flow to the kidney
can cause reduced
activity of the kidney,
kidney impairment,
kidney insufficiency.
And therefore,
all these waste
products, these
nitrogenous
waste products,
can accumulate.
Now, this is
an interesting
one we don't see
all the time.
Unreliable, uncooperative
patients. The
drug has to be taken
at least twice a day.
Dosing is really
complicated.
Therapy has to
be carefully
monitored, and the
drugs can cause this
severe orthostatic
hypotension.
So, as I said in In
the beginning, the
effects are complicated
and unpredictable.
So if a patient is
going to be taking this
drug, the patient needs
to be well informed
of what they can
possibly do and
the fact that they
need to be carefully
monitored and
the orthostatic
hypotension that
can cause falling.
Here are a few questions.
I invite you to pause
the computer, take
a look at the questions,
see if you can
answer them without
looking, and if you
can't, by all means
look back at the
PowerPoint and you
will find the answers.
So I'll give
them to you now.
These are posted
it at the end of
the PowerPoint,
please don't look.
This is intended
to help you try
and solidify
that information
in those good
brains of yours.
Ganglion blockers
suppress all autonomic
outflow of the
neuronal nicotinic
receptors at the
parasympathetic sympathetic
ganglia and the
adrenal medulla, and
this suppresses all
autonomic outflow and
suppresses autonomic
homeostatic reflexes
that normally
moderate autonomic
responses. Normal cardiac,
vascular, neurologic,
muscle, and
neurohumeral reflexes.
Mechanism, orthostatic
hypotension, which
is a significant drop
in blood pressure on
standing, and syncope
is pronounced because
postural reflexes,
which are sympathetic
responses that
normally prevent venous
pooling, are abolished.
Symptoms are dizziness,
lightheadedness, and
fainting. Syncope.
Why should mechamelamine
be prescribed
for patients
who are reliable
and cooperative
with the therapy?
Because the dosing
can be complicated,
therapies must
be monitored,
and the drugs cause
ozostatic hypotension.
Since it's rarely
used, why should
students learn about
it? Well, it might
appear on a board
exam, but other
than that, understanding
the effects of
ganglion blockers
requires a deep
knowledge of autonomic
nervous system.
Grasping the concepts
means students
can appreciate how
ganglion blockers
influence various
physiologic processes
and manage the
potential side effects
and clinical
implications effectively.
Because the bottom line?
Because understanding
the autonomic
nervous system and
what it does and what
blocking it does,
is important to your
medical knowledge
and medical practice.
So let's move now to the
neuromuscular blocking
agents, NMBAs.
There are four that
are starred, and
they are in two
different groups, the
isoquinolines, which
are atricurium and
cis-atricurium, so
you can see that's an
enantiomer, and
the amino steroids
which are called
rocuronium and vecuronium.
I'm sure you
recognize suffix here.
Curium and curium
like curare
and ronium,
ronium, ronium.
And of course
succinylcholine, a very
important and widely
used depolarizing
neuromuscular
blocking agent.
Picture here,
just to remind you
a little bit
about the synapse
at the neuromuscular
junction.
Here we have the bouton
in French, or the button.
Let me see some
buttons over here.
I'm not going to
touch the picture
because it's
giving me messages.
An action potential
comes on down that
neuron, the calcium
channels open, the calcium
rushes in, the vesicles
move to the plasma
membrane, exocytose
their neurotransmitter
contents into the
synapse, Acetylcholine,
and acetylcholine
that bumps into the
nicotinic receptors
binds to its receptor
site, causes opening
of the channel, and
that in turn produces
an action potential
down through the
muscle fibers, causing
muscle contraction. so
that we have the non
-depolarizing blockers
and the depolarizing
blocker, which I'll
get into more detail.
First, we need to look at
the nicotinic receptor.
Again, the circled
one on panel B
there at the top is
the neuromuscular
nicotinic receptor
configuration.
There are two
alpha subunits,
a delta, beta
1, and a gamma.
An older
patient, in older
people, it would
be an epsilon.
The neuronal
nicotinic receptors,
again, they've shaped
exactly the same,
but they have
different subunits.
This one is an example
of a neuromuscular,
sorry, a nicotinic
receptor with only alpha
subunits, and these red
circles here are the
binding sites of
acetylcholine, and this
is another type. So
there are various types.
The cation flows through
the open channel.
And when the
channel has not
been activated,
it's closed.
Here is a
acetylcholine binding
pocket. There's
another acetylcholine
binding pocket
back there.
Structure activity
relationship.
Acetylcholine
at the top to
remind you about
the structure,
simple structure.
Succinylcholine
is just two
acetylcholines
hooked together.
It's indicated in
this illustration in
such a way that you
can see that it's
actually two
acetylcholines here. But
it's really a
linear molecule, and
it's a floppy molecule.
It's flexible.
The NMBAs,
neuromuscular blocking
agents that are
non-depolarizing,
the isoquinolines
and aminosteroids,
you can see,
are much bigger.
This is pancuronium,
not used much anymore.
but it was the first
one of the group and
see how bulky and
rigid the structure
looks even even just
laid out like this.
This is mivacurium,
a benzyl
isoquinoline, also
no longer in use,
but it is representative
of the structure
of the benzyl isoquinolines.
Again, a larger
bulkier molecule
than succinylcholine.
Pancuronium, they've
outlined here the
acetylcholine-like
components of the structure.
So let's begin.
Of course you
need to know all
class actions and
effects and you
need to know the
starred ones by
name, their specific
pharmacology.
Knowing the class
actions, though, and
effects, start with
that. Start here in your
learning, even before
you learn a drug name,
because the drugs are
going to have class
actions and effects.
There and maybe a
couple of other features
that set them apart.
Put the benzyl
isoquinolines at the
top and the amino
steroids at the
bottom for no
particular reason.
Atricurium and
cis-atricurium,
obviously the cis isomer.
Atricurium, hepatic
hydrolysis, and something
called spontaneous
Hoffman elimination.
What Hoffman
elimination is,
it's just a
chemical reaction.
It doesn't require
enzymes, doesn't
occur in the liver,
doesn't occur
in the kidney.
It's just this
spontaneous degradation
of the molecule.
Laudanazine happens
to be a byproduct
of Hoffman elimination
of atricurium.
Okay this is not
usually a big
deal. It is a
CNS stimulant,
doesn't have any
blocking activity,
has a longer half
-life and it can
accumulate and once
it gets into the CNS,
it's excitatory, it
can cause seizures.
But this only occurs
with long infusions
such as being given to
to a person in the ICU
for management of
mechanical ventilation.
So atricurium really
is not the best choice
for management of
mechanical ventilation.
Cis atricurium
also undergoes
Hoffman elimination,
but it is given at
a much lower dose
because it's more
potent than atracurium.
And therefore,
this laudanosine
byproduct just
doesn't accumulate
to any significant
degree.
Let's talk about onset.
Not exactly fast,
two minutes is
kind of a long
time when you're
waiting for the
paralysis to occur.
Recovery, this is
all related to, draw
your attention down
here to the bottom,
plasma clearance,
and that's what
we're talking about
with elimination,
volume of distribution,
elimination half-lives
may be influenced
by patient age, volatile
anesthetics, and the
presence of renal or
hepatic disease
depending on the
drug, which is why
we get this range.
So, duration is
about 20 to 35
minutes, but it can
take an hour and a
half for the
atricurium to clear out
enough that there
is 95% recovery.
Cysatricurium, again,
the total duration
is dose-dependent,
and these other
factors as well
that I mentioned.
Looking at the
amino steroids,
rocuronium is
mainly biliary.
Not much goes
through the kidney.
It's got an
onset of one to
two minutes. This
is quick now.
This is considered quick.
And it can have a
typical duration. It
can be short, like
this, like the others,
or quite long,
depending on the
dose and the
patient factors.
Vecuronium, now this
goes through biliary
secretion and biliary,
think liver, and
renal. So this is
the only one in the
group that is excreted
through the kidneys.
Onset, it's pretty long,
two and a half
to three minutes.
Recovery, pretty
typical of the others.
All right, let's look
at potency for a moment.
Potency is related to
tubocuraring potency,
so that's one. That
was the first one.
That is the prototype
of this group. It's
not used anymore
because it will block
neuronal nicotinic receptors
and cause histamine
to be released and
cause significant
side effects. So compared
to tubulcururine,
atricurium,
cis-atricurium are
a bit more potent.
Vecuronium is a
lot more potent.
But rocuronium is less
potent. So what does
all this potency
business mean? It has
to do with how much
drug is going to be
administered in order
to produce an effect.
I'm sure you remember the
basic pharmacology
principle.
that a less potent
drug requires
more molecules of
the drug to be at
the site of action
to have enough
molecules there to
produce the effect.
Association,
dissociation constants,
all that basic
pharmacodynamics.
So all this is
telling us is that
rocuronium needs
more molecules
to be administered
to produce the
effect, it'll be
the same effect,
and as a result
of all these
molecules flowing
into the synapse,
it can have a
faster onset
because there's
just more molecules
being administered
because
of the dosing,
simple concept.
All right, mechanism.
At the top, we have a
normally functioning
nicotinic receptor.
These little spheres
are acetylcholine.
Acetylcholine
enters a synapse,
binds to its
receptor, which
is right here
on this figure,
and causes
channel opening.
This oval is now
in a vertical
conformation
and sodium here
flows through.
That's the normal.
Notice that the
acetylcholine has to be
in high enough quantity
in order for it
to accidentally bump
into the receptor,
bind to it and
activate it. Here this
is just a molecule
that's going off
directly into the
acetylcholinesterase for
degradation into
choline and acetate.
Now on the bottom
part here we have
our acetylcholine
again and we
have our non
-depolarizing blocker.
Here's the key and it
is this light colored
sphere that is
yellow is on the
acetylcholine receptor
site and it's preventing
opening of the
channel. So that's it,
competitive antagonist,
simple concept.
Here we have the
depolarizing blocker,
succinylcholine is the
only one in clinical use,
this new thing,
where these are
depolarizing blocker, and
this is a darker blue
color, is binding to
the acetylcholine
receptor, and also it's
kind of stuck here in
the channel as well.
So it will initially
open, see the channel
is initially opened,
sodium will flow
through before the
drug actually gets
stuck in the channel,
And once it's in
the channel, sodium
cannot flow through,
the channel is
blocked, even though
you see it in the
open confirmation.
That's the basic
difference.
Competitive antagonism
versus initial
opening and then block,
depolarizing block.
You don't need
to memorize this
slide. It's here
for context.
It's helpful to
understand the
order in which
the muscles become
paralyzed. So the
small ones first,
then muscles of the
limbs and trunk and
abdomen, then the
intercostal, so we
have our respiratory
muscles, and finally
the diaphragm and
respiration ceases.
Patient is not able
to breathe because of
the muscle paralysis
and once the drug is
withdrawn and wears
off, is eliminated,
it's the function returns
in the reverse order.
So what do we use
these for? Well to
facilitate intubation
to relax the
laryngeal and jaw muscles
to get the patient
intubated, to
facilitate surgery,
operative manipulation,
to cause those
muscles to relax
for easier surgery.
Importantly, by
administering a
neuromuscular
blocking agent, less
surgical anesthesia
can be used.
If the neuromuscular
blocker is not
administered, it takes
a greater depth of
surgical anesthesia in
order to bring about
neuromuscular block
with the anesthetic.
So giving the
neuromuscular blocker,
we can give less
anesthesia because
the level of
anesthesia needs to be
to the level of
sedation, but not
neuromuscular block.
We also use them for
mechanical ventilation,
patients in the ICU
who are on mechanical
ventilation because as
you would anticipate,
thoracic compliance
is improved by giving,
by paralyzing
the muscles.
And they can
be used as an
adjunct in orthopedic
procedures.
These are intuitive.
You could
imagine that the
neuromuscular
blockers would be
really useful for
these purposes.
Please, please remember.
Consciousness and
sensorium are intact.
The patient is
conscious. The
patient is
aware of what's
going on. The
patient can feel.
The patient can feel
pain. they're not
responding and therefore
you they're not giving
any signals when
they're in pain please
remember that delivering
a neuromuscular
blocking agent is not
the same as anesthesia
anesthesia needs to
be administered and
And of course, monitored.
Everything
gets monitored.
These are not,
these are
potentially serious.
These are, these drugs
should be used by
people who are
experienced in their use.
Okay, reversal.
All right, patient
has undergone the
surgery or whatever
procedure, and now the
neuromuscular blocking
agent is withdrawn.
It's no longer
being administered.
You may recall that the
time to 95% recovery
can be half an hour to
two hours, depending
on the drug. So a
reversal agent is
appropriate. Looking
first at the
benzyl isylcholines
here, atricurium and
cis-atricurium, use
a cholinesterase
inhibitor. Remember, these
are competitive
antagonists. So what are
we going to do? We are
going to increase the
amount of acetylcholine
in the synapse to
out-compete the neuromuscular
blocker. A basic
pharmacologic principle
put into action.
Neostigmine is
the cholinesterase
inhibitor most used
for this purpose.
Should there be a
shortage or some
reason, neostigmine
is not available,
pyridostigmine
can also be used.
The aminosteroids,
the rocuronium and
becuronium specifically,
and just those two,
can be reversed
using a drug
by the name of Sigamidex.
Picture of it
here. I mean this
is a representation
by an artist.
These molecules
in here, this
represents the
amino steroid.
The sagamidex is the
cyclodextrin,
it's called.
And it actually
encases, traps, envelops
the neuromuscular
blocker in there.
And then it's done
in a one-to-one
ratio, one molecule
to one molecule,
just the way this
figure represents.
Complexes are
created in the
urine. It acts
very rapidly.
Cholinesterase
inhibitors can be
used as well.
Sagamidex is expensive.
And if there's a
shortage of it,
it's also nice to
know that we can
use a cholinesterase
inhibitor.
so we have a couple
of notations here
about these drugs
let's look at the
cholinesterase inhibitors
first well it's
cholinesterase inhibitor
it's increasing
acetylcholine levels
not only in the
neuromuscular junction
but everywhere and that
can cause the secretions
increasing secretions
it can cause this
vagal stimulation
which will cause slow
heart rate bradycardia
Large doses
administered when the
neuromuscular block is
minimal, in other words,
when the patient is
nearing recovery,
can result in
more block because
excessive acetylcholine
in the neuromuscular
junction will lead
to a depolarizing.
Go back to our
cholinesterase inhibitors
pharmacology
and look at the
potential adverse
effects of the drugs.
Sigamidex is generally
quite well tolerated.
The serious
adverse effects
are rare. It's just a
one-time dose
usually to trap
the aminosteroid
and quickly
remove it from
the bloodstream.
What can happen
though? We always
need to know what
can happen. So
bradycardia and ECG
abnormalities so
we just hook them
up. Monitor it.
The drug is
encapsulating this amino
steroid. It is a
steroid structure.
It doesn't have any
steroid activity,
but it is a
steroid structure.
And so it can actually
also capture the
steroids in
contraceptive, in hormonal
contraceptive,
and that could at
least transiently
reduce the effectiveness
of the contraceptive.
Individuals should be
made aware of that.
It can increase
coagulation
parameters. This
is something they
would like to ask
on a board exam.
Fortunately,
clinically significant
bleeding has not
been reported in
all the years of
use of the drug.
So let's take now a
look at the adverse
effects of these
blocking agents.
Prolonged apnea, as
you would expect.
So So think about risk
factors for the patient.
If there's inadequate
reversal, of
course, so that must
be carefully monitored
to make sure the
patient recovers.
Residual neuromuscular
block, prolonged
surgery, opioids, all
of these things will
prolong the potential
of respiratory
suppression due to
prolonged recovery rates.
Electrolyte abnormalities,
acidosis, hypokalemia,
hypocalcemia, and
too much magnesium.
Potassium, calcium low,
magnesium high,
and acidosis.
Burns. Caution.
Do not give
it to patients
with burns.
Because they already
have myopathies,
they already have
too much potassium,
and giving a
neuromuscular blocker
can increase the
muscle damage.
So we get increased doses
that would be needed.
Diseases where
there is already a
myasthenic syndrome,
let's call it.
So there's reduced
activity at
the neuromuscular
junction because
of these autoimmune
diseases.
As always,
the very young and very
old will be
more sensitive.
It's true with
practically all drugs.
Practically all
drugs can potentially
cause hypersensitivity
reactions
in the vulnerable
individual.
Fortunately, these are
rare. And then drug
interactions,
anything that causes a
greater degree of
neuromuscular blockade.
Aminoglycosides
and certain
other antibiotics
can cause
neuromuscular
block on their own.
So we're putting in a
neuromuscular blocker
and there can be an
exaggerated effect.
Some drugs
potentiate or inhibit
NMBA effects and
all of respiratory
depression,
electrolyte imbalance.
Basically what
we're talking about
with these drug
interactions is drugs
that also cause all
of these effects.
All right, so in
summary, let's compare
the different ones.
I've put here in bold
and the color I put
them in is red, so
that you can figure
out what exactly are
the differences
between these drugs if
I want to be
selecting the perfect
neuromuscular blocking
agent for my patient.
Atricurium causes
histamine release,
and histamine
release causes skin
flushing as there's
vasodilation in
the superficial
vessels of the skin.
Hypotension from
vasodilation again.
And tachycardia, because
this is a homeostatic
reflex, reflex
tachycardia to hypotension
that I mentioned
earlier in the lecture.
Metabolism.
Well, it's this plasma
esterase, so
that's liver.
and this Hoffman
elimination,
which is laudanazine.
And the laudanazine
can accumulate,
and that can
cause seizure.
But this is, of course,
long infusions
of this drug.
It can be given in
renally impaired patients
because it doesn't go
through the kidney.
Now, cis-atricurium,
the cis-enantiomer, the
cis-isomer, is Hoffman
elimination, but
it's given it a much
lower dose, so the
laudanazine is not likely
to accumulate. So, the
takeaway here is cis
-atricurium does not
cause significant
laudanazine accumulation.
Procuronium, quick
onset, and when
we think quick
onset, we think it
can be used for
rapid sequence
intubation, which
it frequently is.
That's the big
difference here.
It can be given
to patients with
renal impairment,
remember that it has
between rocuronium
and vecuronium,
it has really minor
renal secretion.
So vecuronium, what's
the takeaway here?
Not suitable for rapid
sequence intubation
and also hepatic
metabolism and excretion
through the biliary
and renal roots.
Therefore, patients
with liver or kidney
impairment may have
a prolonged response
because it is not being
cleared out as fast.
Basic pharmacology
principles
you've already
learned very well.
So let's talk about
succinylcholine now, the
depolarizing neuromuscular
blocking agent.
Some pharmacokinetic
information,
succinylcholine,
remember it's two
acetylcholines together,
is metabolized by
plasmacholinesterase,
but not by
acetylcholinesterase,
but it is by
plasmacholinesterase.
Therefore, the drug
is put into a vein,
passes through the
bloodstream and a
small fraction of
the dose actually
reaches the motor end
plate and the dosing
has been figured
out based on this.
Onset, less than a minute
basically, really quick,
short duration of action.
Pharmacogenomics, think
about
plasmacolinesterase,
pharmacogenomics.
In patients with
deficient or
absent
plasmacolinesterase,
because of these
genetic variants,
B stands for butyral
colonesterase,
which is the gene that
produces this protein,
that expresses
this protein,
plasmacolinesterase. If
deficient, that same dose
that's given to a person
with normally functioning
plasma cholinesterase
is going to get
a larger fraction of
succinylcholine at the
neuromuscular end
plate, and that's going
to cause an increased
duration of effect.
So please remember this
pharmacogenomics
principle.
Fortunately, it's
really rare, but it's
still something you
need to remember.
Very short duration
because it's rapidly
hydrolyzed by the liver
butyrocholinesterase
and plasmacholinesterase,
but mainly plasma.
Not degraded by
acetylcholinesterase,
but it is by
plasmacholinesterase.
Remember, plasma
cholinesterase is
also called
pseudo, pseudo
cholinesterase,
they're the same thing.
Succinylcholine blockade
is terminated by
diffusion, the drug
diffuses out of the
synapse. It is not
terminated using a
cholinesterase inhibitor
because that would
increase levels of
acetylcholine in the
synapse along with
the succinylcholine.
And remember the
effect of depolarizing.
Block was too much
acetylcholine.
So that's just going to
make the block stronger.
Mechanism of action.
Yes, this is
something you
really should understand.
There is an initial
stimulation as the
succinylcholine binds to
the acetylcholine receptor
sites, it causes
opening of the channel.
That's the initial
thing that happens, the
opening of the channel.
So the membranes
are depolarized, and
that's going to cause
these spontaneous
little twitchings, and
that's called fasciculations.
You should know
this word, fasciculations.
as the calcium is
released from the
sarcoplasmic reticulum.
Then the membranes
become depolarized
and unresponsive
to subsequent
impulses. Maybe you
can visualize that
little figure we saw
in the beginning.
And the succinylcholine
finds its way
into the actual channel
as well as putting
a block on the
acetylcholine receptors
and that will cause
flaccid paralysis,
skeletal muscle
relaxation.
Succinylcholine
is usually
given as a short dose
and we get this is
the block that occurs.
At higher doses, phase
two block can occur
where the membranes
now become repolarized.
However, they
are desensitized.
The mechanism
isn't clear.
In all these years, it
hasn't been defined.
But the channels
behave as though
they're in a prolonged
closed state.
And later, in
phase 2 block,
which is a much
higher dose or a
much longer
duration of time,
then it becomes like a
non-depolarizing block.
Well, succinylcholine
is associated with
a number, a number
of adverse effects.
You will appreciate
knowing them at some
point in the future,
and I highly recommend
that you do get an
understanding of the
mechanisms of all of
these side effects.
So malignant
hyperthermia, this is
something that's seen
in pediatric patients
who have an
undiagnosed skeletal
muscle myopathy, like
muscular dystrophy.
It hasn't been diagnosed.
Abnormal release of
calcium stores in
the skeletal muscle
in these patients
who have this
myopathy. So this
large amount of calcium
that is released
into the cytosol
causes hyperthermia,
too much potassium,
hyperkalemia,
acidosis,
hemoglobinuria,
myoglobinuria, and
cardiovascular
complications. Very serious.
Volatile anesthetics
can do this too,
and we will be
talking about volatile
anesthetics in a
future lecture.
Treatment, I know
you probably haven't
had the pharmacology
of dantrolene, so
we'll just give you
the high points here.
This is not only
a board-relevant
treatment, it is
a patient-relevant
treatment, clinically
relevant. it.
So dantrolene blocks
ryanodine receptors
type 1, which are
in skeletal muscle.
By doing so, that
prevents the release of
calcium from the
skeletal muscles. So that
makes sense that it
would be the treatment.
Masseter spasm, well,
this is in the lower jaw.
That muscle can spasm.
It appears to
be associated
with this whole
muscle myopathy
issue in pediatric
patients.
Myalgia, rhabdomyolysis,
myoglobinumia,
and this is because
of muscle damage.
Damage to the
skeletal muscle cells.
And what happens
when skeletal muscle
cells are damaged?
They release their
contents into the
bloodstream. And
we think about
especially potassium
being released into
the bloodstream.
Again, hyperkalemia keeps
popping up, doesn't it?
And hyperkalemia
all on its own row.
Rapid loss of
intracellular potassium,
such as occurs
in patients with
burns, burn patients,
extensive burns.
Neuromuscular trauma,
trauma patients,
patients with certain
neuromuscular diseases.
And this hyperkalemia
can be life
-threatening, which is
why we keep bringing
it up. It causes
cardiac arrhythmias,
and it can cause
the heart to stop.
Speaking of cardiac
arrhythmias,
this has its own row.
Ventricular arrhythmias
resulting from
hyperkalemic
rhabdomyolysis. You see
how these are building
on each other?
Easy to remember
if you start
building your foundation
and putting your
structure on top of it.
Bradycardia now,
this seems to
be related to
the metabolite,
succinyl monocholine.
So that's a matter
of monitoring.
And atropine or
glycopyrrolate,
Mentioned in the anti
-muscarinic lecture.
Pre-treatment to
prevent the bradycardia.
And that will, of
course, also prevent the
excess secretions,
salivary secretions,
respiratory secretions.
Oh, but we're not done.
Increase in intragastric
pressures, pressure
in the stomach.
And that can cause,
what are we worried
about? well these
patients are
undergoing surgery so
we're afraid now of
aspiration and
aspiration of stomach
contents can lead
to being going into
the lungs causing
aspiration pneumonia
increase in intraocular
pressure again
it's the muscle
fasciculations around these
eye muscles and
that's going to cause
distortion and compression
of the globe so
that will increase
the pressure inside.
Increased intracranial
pressure, this is
a transient effect.
There have been a
number of proposals
as to the mechanism.
It seems though to
result from stimulation
of afferent muscle
activity because of all
of this muscle
fasciculation. And that, in
turn, is a reflex
that's going to increase
cerebral blood flow,
at least transiently.
Plasma colon
esterase deficiency,
I referred to
that earlier.
Pharmacogenomics,
the BCHE gene.
I use a capital for that.
and that can cause
prolonged apnea
with the
succinylcholine dose
because a greater
amount of the
succinylcholine
reaches the synapse.
This is a congenital
homozygous
for atypical BCHE gene.
Also, plasma cholinesterase
deficiency can
be acquired. Burned
patients, anemia,
decompensated heart disease,
infections, malignant
tumors, severe hepatic
dysfunction, why?
Because it's made
in the liver,
pregnancy, and others.
Hypersensitivity,
always ask,
history of allergic
reaction to succinylcholine
or any component
of the formulation.
So contraindications
now follow
from all that
we've talked
about up to this point.
Anybody who's had a
history of malignant
hyperthermia clearly
should not get this drug.
Anyone with myopathy,
muscle paralysis,
has increased
risk for malignant
hyperthermia and
should not get it.
Rhabdomyolysis, ditto.
Multiple trauma, and we
have that muscle trauma.
Spinal cord or
upper motor,
neuron injury,
major burns.
ocular injury
because of this
risk of hyperkalemia
that can
lead to arrhythmias
and death. I
have a few
questions here. I
recommend that you
pause your computer
and see if you
can answer them.
So here they are.
Mechanistically, what
is the difference
between depolarizing
block and non
-depolarizing block?
Depolarizing block,
the drug initially
causes ion
channel opening,
membrane depolarization
and activation,
followed by
depolarization, was
unresponsive to
subsequent impulses.
Competitive inhibitors
of acetylcholine at
the binding pockets
prevent channel opening.
What are the
mechanisms of action of
the neuromuscular
blockade reversal
agents for each of
the NMBA subclasses?
So the isoquinolines,
cholinesterase
inhibitors,
increase synaptic
concentrations of
acetylcholine to
out-compete the non
-deprolarizing neuromuscular
blocking agent.
Aminosteroids, generally
sagamidex, if available.
This is the cyclodextrin,
as I mentioned,
that complexes
with the amino
steroid in a one-to
-one ratio in plasma.
And that will cause
a rapid decline
in the NMBA plasma
concentrations as
the complex is
excreted in the urine.
And succinylcholine
diffuses out of the
synapse, terminating
neuromuscular block.
Which non-depolarizing
NMBA may cause
prolonged duration
of blockade in
patients with liver
or kidney impairment?
So we think about
vecuronium especially for
the kidney impairment
because it is excreted
in liver and I mean
especially for both
liver and kidney
impairments is what I'm
I'm trying to say,
because it's excreted
through the liver, the
biliary system, and
excreted through the
kidneys and the urine.
So impairment of these
organs can increase
the duration of
blockade, prolong the
blockade, because
the drug is not being
cleared as quickly
as in other people.
So which NMBA that
starred can cause flushing
and hypotension. And
what is the cause?
Well, you see, flushing
and hypotension,
something that
should jump to your
mind right away is
histamine release.
So atricurium releases
histamine, which acts
on vascular histamine
receptors causing
vasodilation, thus a
drop in blood pressure,
hypotension, and skin
reddening, flushing.
Which NMBA can
cause malignant
hyperthermia
in individuals
with skeletal
muscle disease?
Ah, I know, I don't even
have to show
you the answer.
Of course, it's
succinylcholine
and also inhaled
anesthetics.
What is the effect of
NMBA administration
to patients with
autoimmune diseases,
myasthenia gravis
and Lambert
-Eaton myasthenic
syndrome?
This is an
autoimmune disease.
Both of them are
autoimmune diseases.
Myasthenia gravis
is antibodies
against the
nicotinic receptors
in the neuromuscular
junction.
Lambert-Eaton
myasthenic syndrome is a
decrease in the amount
of acetylcholine that's
released from the
presynaptic terminals.
Either way,
these people are
already at risk for
muscle weakness.
What is the
mechanism of muscle
fasciculations caused
by succinylcholine?
The depolarizing
block binding to the
acetylcholine
receptors, initially
causing ion channel
opening and movement
of the sodium
through the channel
leading to depolarization
of the membranes
causing small
spontaneous twitching.
List the serious
adverse effects
related to muscle
fasciculations.
Rhabdomyolysis,
hyperkalemia,
cardiac dysrhythmia,
increased
intragastric and
intraocular pressure.
What is the potential
mechanism of
the transient
increased intracranial
pressure caused by
succinylcholine.
Well, one proposed
mechanism,
which is likely,
is stimulation
of the afferent
muscle activity
leading to
transient increased
blood flow,
cranial blood flow,
that will, I should say,
may stimulate afferent
muscle activity
leading to
transient increased
cerebral blood flow, and
that will transiently
increase intracranial
pressure.
Remember,
succinylcholine does not
cross the blood
-brain barrier. None
of these neuromuscular
blocking agents
crosses the blood
-brain barrier.
What is the name of
the byproduct of NMBA
metabolism that in
high concentrations is
associated with
lowering the seizure
threshold? So it's stated
a little differently
so you can think
about it in this way.
And that of course
is atricurium, the
Hoffman elimination
that produces
laudanazine, which in
high concentrations,
because of its
long half-life, can
accumulate in the CNS
and cause seizures.
What drugs can
be administered
before succinylcholine
to mitigate
the bradycardia
caused by the NMBA?
Well, think
about what causes
bradycardia?
Vagal stimulation.
So how can we
block the vagal
stimulation causing
the bradycardia?
Which is muscarinic
receptors,
anti-muscarinic
drugs, atropine or
glycopyrrolate. Atropine
is the prototype
of the group.
Glycopyrrolate does
not cross the blood
-brain barrier.
And the bradycardia
is attributed
to the succinyl
monocholine,
not the
succinylcholine itself.
Rapid-sequence
intubation. Both
succinylcholine,
commonly used,
and rocuronium
have a rapid onset
of action. For
pediatric patients,
rocuronium is often
used because of the
frequently undiagnosed
muscular myopathies.
Succinylcholine
is contraindicated
in what conditions?
Patients with a history
of malignant
hyperthermia.
Myopathy or
muscle paralysis.
rhabdomyolysis,
multiple trauma,
spinal cord or upper
motor neuron injury,
major burns, ocular
injury, and we are
worried about
exaggerated hyperkalemia.
So in summary, I'll
let you read these
to yourself. We've
talked about them and
summarize them
extensively as of now.
This is here
just to kind of
give you a
little reminder.
And the check
your knowledge
questions that we
just talked about.
On the left are two
anesthesiologists who
are inserting an
endotracheal tube and on
the right is the
monitoring of the hand for
neuromuscular transmission
of the blocker.
And that concludes
this lecture.